Good evening my name is Paul Holden Grabe I'm the director of public programs here at the New York Public
Library known as LIVE FROM the New York Public Library as you know my goal at the
library is to make the Lion's Roar to make a heavy institution dense and if
successful to make it levitate.
It is a pleasure to welcome you to the LIVE FROM the New York Public Library spring season.
I'd like to update our announcement.
You might have received a flier.
Next week we have a Rose Garden Syria who has fled speaking about
criticism on the sixteenth of March we have met mountain the president
of the Association of universities for research in
astronomy working on the James Webb telescope the successor to
the Hubble telescope speaking with Nathaniel can who you probably
will recognize as a great film maker of my architect about his father
Louis can they will be
speaking about astronomy. Then we have artist my
Ellyn music musician Rosanne Cash
cash. YANIS VAROUFAKIS a former finance minister of Greece. I'm happy
to let you know that as of today. Chomsky is accepted
to interview
him. I don't know is that I don't know if that is a
good but I think so. Following.
Noam Chomsky we have Seymour Hersh one of the great investigative journalists who won
the George Polk
Award five times in the Pulitzer Prize for journalism just once and
the National Magazine Award
twice and the L.A. Times Book Prize a National Book Critics of war just once
he will be live here as well talking about the
killing of Osama bin Laden would have the great photographer the great magnum
photographer Bruce Davidson the artist Sarah to say Siddhartha Mukherjee the
cancer physician and researcher winner of the Pulitzer Prize. We have a lot of Pulitzer Prize
winners in general nonfiction in two thousand and eleven also of the Emperor of All
Maladies A Biography of Cancer he will be joined and I'm updating your
schedule now by David Remnick the editor of The New Yorker to discuss his forthcoming book
The gene An Intimate History.
Julian Barnes new novel is on show a stack of it. And this year's
Nobel Prize for a plan a legacy of each will be joined in conversation by Katherine Boo.
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar will be joined by Walter Mosley Kareem is passionate about Sherlock Holmes
actually even more so of micro Mycroft Holmes Sherlock
Holmes Brothers and a big fan of the detective fiction of Walter
Mosley we will in all likelihood and I would spring season with Laurie
Anderson I say in all likelihood
because with me you just never know I might add a little bit
of salt and pepper to the season if you feel that more salt and more pepper
is
needed. I would like to say a big thank you to the Ford
Foundation for their fantastic support of LIVE FROM the New York Public Library as
well as his support of many other great cultural institutions across New
York City thanks also go
to the continuing generosity of Celeste and
Adam
battles one ninety two books our great
independent bookseller has precise and copies of Jhumpa Lahiri his new book
In other
words it's my very very great pleasure to open
the season with Jhumpa Lahiri back from for the second time live from the New
York Public Library the last time she was here with the mirror and. I had to look up when
that was it was on March tenth two thousand and seven nine years
ago. When they spoke about the adaptation of The Namesake.
Just as it had come out the also of the interpreter of Maladies a
Pulitzer Prize winner John. Well I hear it and I will discuss tonight. Her newest book.
In other
words written in Italian and translated into English by
and Goldstein an editor at The New Yorker and translator among
others of a lot Elin Frank and Prima Levy.
As you know for the last seven or eight years I've asked all of my guests to provide me
a biography of themselves in seven words a haiku of sorts so if you're very modern to tweet.
I
usually proclaim them seven words but I will withhold the
pleasure for a while and we will regale you with those seven words
which Drupal here you wrote in Italian towards the end of our conversation.
Now it is my great
privilege and pleasure. To bring Jhumpa Lahiri to this stage.
Thank you
Lou
Thank you.
I'd like to Brit. Begin by speaking about midlife crisis
of.
Tony
job in a fantastic essay called midlife
crisis in the memory chalet has a following to say bear with me
it will take about a minute.
Other men change why it's. Some change
cause some. Change gender the point of the midlife crisis is
to demonstrate continuity with one's use by doing something strikingly
different to be sure different is a relative term a
man in the throes of such a crisis usually does the same as every other
man that after all is how we
know it's a midlife crisis but mine was a little different.
I was the right age at the right time divorcing wife number
two and experiencing the usual mid middle age
and certainties.
What is all this about but I did it my
way I look and check.
Earning check made
me a very different sort of scholar historian and Perth.
Would have made me a significant difference. Had I taken up say a
polish my friends certainly saw
though to then check with a small slab
language much as Russian colleagues would later describe Polish and I
had inexplicably opted to specialize in what for them was
the equivalent of the history of say the way he
is but without my Czech obsession I would not have found myself in power.
In November one thousand nine hundred eighty nine watching have L. accept the
presidency from a balcony in the town square. Above all or
I could never have written post-war my history of Europe since one thousand nine hundred
forty five my chick adventures did not get to me and new
wife until much later and only indirectly much less a new
car but they were the
best mid life crisis. I could have wished
for there were more things in heaven and
is than with Grant of in Western philosophy. And I
had belatedly
see some of them. Jhumpa Lahiri Does that
sound familiar.
Yes Extremely in fact i've of I thought over in recent years that I am.
This is what's happening that it has been a sort of wonderful midlife crisis.
You know the best kind I think you know to have a
relationship with the
language and the fear with the language.
Well and every nation ship that has so
many different. There's so many different ways to look at
it you know and I I explore this a little in the book I
mean thinking of it first in strictly romantic terms
and then and
then feeling a sort of maternal.
Relationship too to the language that's an interesting That was an interesting shift.
You know.
And so I so I reckon I see myself in
that in that passage very much you know and and I think
that in a sense.
Language is the most intimate relationship out of our lives at least I think for
me I mean and this is not to say that I don't love
deeply people and have profound relationships with them
but I think language
is it so much more powerful than we are you know.
And so to have a relationship with languages is a very profound
thing and to go to goes to
to speak another language I think is is so
powerful it's so
humbling this trial and some
way with it the way. A For you to shake yourself
up. I mean it feels when I read. Toni Judd it felt
to me that his mid-life crisis is running track was something he needed.
Well it certainly was a need it comes from a need but the interesting thing is I mean though
I have thought now and
then yes I'm going through some sort of
linguistic midlife crisis identity crisis. I mean. So a
few things I
mean.
I have in a way been preparing for this midlife crisis since I was.
What twenty six or seven years old. So that's interesting
because it's not that suddenly I was capsized
by something in my what I hope is the middle of my life.
So there was this slow preparation from my
youth right. My young adult
years on the other hand I feel I feel like I'm someone who
has developed very slowly as a
person and in lots of ways.
And and I think I was I was a very very
young twenty something year old I wasn't like a lot of other people
I knew who are my age I always felt very behind certain
respects and many respects so.
So yes on the one hand it I think I think of it as a midlife crisis. What I've
done with the telling
and on the other hand I think of it as the real first adolescence of my life.
So how do you reconcile those two things because I feel both the sort
of person in her forty's seeking something radically new
you know and I also feel for the first time.
The child who stood up and said I'm not going to do
that and you know what With comes to my mind you can't reconcile.
But I like it I like it that it has these two dimensions that have this tension Yeah I
mean and in one sense it comes at the right time in my biological
arc because I
am forty eight. So yes it makes sense that
it happened. Now not ten or fifteen or twenty years ago on the other hand I do
feel that it has a powerful adolescent strain. What's happening
here you. You write in your book from the
creative point of view this nothing so dangerous security.
Yes
I do.
And that seems to me the challenge that
YOU YOU YOU
YOU voiding with would have
been Yes well I just feel as
think it's not right it's not right to feel comfortable
and it's not.
It makes me actually sort of anxious to feel
totally settled which is ironic because I'm a sort of profoundly unsettled
person in some senses
having not the sort of points of reference right.
That might settle people.
Or maybe not the traditional points of reference because I do have points of reference in my life
and I sometimes I feel very settled. If you're very rooted as a
person but I didn't I did as a child and if we are formed
by the age of seven then I definitely didn't feel
that.
But now
I've completely lost my train of thought what I wanted to say.
Something I think that's necessary.
Oh no this is what I wanted to say no I think. No I mean I think exactly.
No I mean it's like for example I noticed that the moment in which
I wanted to leave New York when I started to feel the need
to go away and to leave it
behind was precisely at the moment when life was getting very settled.
You know life was getting very settled. We had a house we lived in and we were
raising our children everything was sort of going along in this direction and once I realized
that it had kind of gone into gear and it was moving along that was the moment
I got I had a
sudden deep desire to get out
and see it from a totally different point of view or to not see it at all maybe for
a while just to do something
else that's what I wanted to say you know.
So it's that feeling of and I think especially in terms
of writing in terms of.
Of of the inspiration and and and the
work you know that the strange
contradiction of Italian
which people have I mean I think I have tried to
explain in the book that people ask me about.
When it's
all a series of contradictions this
whole past the whole project but I think that the central one is.
You know I'm I'm looking for some kind of rootedness some kind
of home some kind of place point of reference all of these things that were lacking in
my life and so.
And why because I want to feel comfortable I want to
feel comforted in the world. You know I don't like this sense of. Why
don't I fit. And anywhere why don't I belong anywhere. Why can't I call any place home this anxiety.
And so what do I do I look for it in a totally new
language in which I am completely alien and I feel very much.
I am very much a stranger writer and a foreigner. I mean by definition I am
a foreigner in that language and yet I feel at home. It's
the feeling of feeling at
home within the. Obvious atmosphere
of of of the other and of foreign
this and. And so I think
there's something something to be explored there in that what
do other languages. Give
us and why are we dreaming drilled into
them and I was very struck.
A few weeks ago
I was I teach a translation workshop now it. Princeton so I
was preparing for the class
and and I was reading about I was reading Cicero on translation
and what he thought about you know he had many things to say about
this the say that. There's At a certain point
he says you know it's it's lean wild through it's the language of the
other that
can give bad that can we store to us something that is
missing and when I read that I realized this is what was going on that I was
searching for something I thought I didn't have and it was Italian that gave it to me
and so even though it is. The other it had it was a part of me that
was missing.
If I make myself clear. I hope.
So that struck me very much this idea and the whole project of translation. You know that's what's
behind that's what's driving translation. It's
this this idea of the. The other of the other
but everyone talks about the other but just the other language. You know and that
there is something that we cannot get out of the languages we
have at our disposal.
You know we sometimes speak about the idea that we. That I
cannot
silence.
It so it's so hard to be self reflects a friend's a
person and you're saying the same thing in terms of
language the language in a way no chance
yes it is and revisit sense some way.
Well it's both it's both healing right it's had some sort of curative powers I
think Italian in my life. It's it's sort of curative
Yes I think it's it's it's it's healed a
certain. Maybe not completely but it's it's it's it's given me a
certain echo Librium that I needed in terms of my sort of
personal interior landscape and how I viewed things and
how I viewed myself and how I view things these are being myself
so I think it has had a kind of
curative power and yet it is the language
of for me. These are draw you know it's not a
language in which I never comfortable.
I cannot be comfortable in the language I'm always going to be looking over my shoulder saying thinking.
Did I say that Ray did a spell that right did is that the right word that the right construction. You know
because it's
never it's never a firm under my feet. It's
like it's so extraordinary you were feeling discomfort.
You went to another country and another language to
somehow take yourself out of this feeling of discomfort to end up in
a place which also made you uncomfortable.
Yes but it's like but has a terrific effect at the same
time. I think it's like people who devote themselves to the sea or
something you know it's like sailors It's like people who who can't live on the earth. They can't
do it. Thats too painful. It's too firm. You know.
And so they take to the sea and then they can't come
back begins. Exactly and so this print this metaphor of
the crossing and the water and swimming and I
think it's all kind of connected.
Yes And I think you know. I
remember a few years ago we were sailing around the alien
Islands for a week in a sailboat my family
and with another family with whom we were close friends
and so we all got on to the boat and we're all very excited for this
adventure and I remember what. So we nobody none of us knew how
to sail the boat so we had a very
nice skipper we called him the
skipper
civilian and he said as we were setting
out he said well there's one thing you have to
know which is we don't belong here we're human
beings and we don't belong on the
water and it's dangerous and it can kill us and if it's not where
we're supposed to be and you have to know this and you have to respect that and you have to
respect the sea because it's so much powerful than we are and it really doesn't like
us and yet we love it and we're going to sail
and we're going to have a great week and we
did you know I mean he said it in a much found beautiful way than I am.
But I was really struck by what he
said because I think it's true and I and I immediately thought of my relationship to
Italian and I thought that that's Italian. For me I'm
sailing through this language and it's dangerous and I don't belong in it.
And yet it's
it's this sort of sublime experience for me you know you need to respect this.
And as well I need to respect it. You know I need to
respect what it is and what it is in relationship to me
and the distance between us that remains forever and I have to
respect that even if I mean look we one can learn how
to swim.
You know one can survive in the water up to a certain point and but then after a certain point
one will drop right. I mean we are not made to live in the water we're not fish.
So that's what the skipper was saying we're not fish we're human beings and we're not meant to be
here this is not our our
element. But I thought that was
very you know it sort of put things clearly for
me you know one of those moments but these things happened to me
in Italian you know these things happen when to me often with Italians who say
things like this and suddenly
everything is very clear. One thing
that
struck me is. You talk
about about
the slowness the necessity of slowness
and it reminded me of a wonderful line in preventing any that but and then
you mean mentions me says Martin. No longer works at
what cannot
be abbreviated.
Well certainly learning a language cannot be abbreviated and it's just a
constant prolongation rather right and it never ends.
You can never end you can never stop learning another language
because it's like exploring the Pacific Ocean. I
mean part of the journey towards Italy was
a way of going
from a sense of failure here in this
country towards anonymity.
Well
in the real sense of the word of not quite having a.
I was I don't really think about those things very much I don't.
I don't really think of myself as being famous really in my
day to day like it doesn't really you know I'm not really aware of it but I but I like the.
I like the feeling of returning to a sort
of solitary state of feeling like an
apprentice I like that I liked
feeling that I like the
idea of writing something and
feeling kind of embarrassed about it I like that
feeling and I because I felt that when I first started writing I felt mortified.
I was so shamed I was so embarrassed I was so afraid that I was writing.
Because it wasn't something that
was well for a variety of reasons or shall we say it just wasn't something
I thought comes comfortable confident doing and I was always sort
of pushing it away hoping it would not bother me anymore.
I think we'll
have a variety of reasons. When I
imagine that that phrase of you might
indicate the two passages which I read very quickly from In other
words which talk about you.
I mean for me they talk very much about you your tactile
you kind of tension feeling. They tell you
in language you say from the start my relationship with.
Italy is as Harry. Or the Terry. As it is
visually. I feel a connection and at the same time a detachment
a closeness and the same time distance but I feel it's
something physical inexplicably
it's
discreet a piece.
An exquisite tension
love at first sight.
That seems it reminded
me of a line I think that
it's mentioned here that in Latin America when makes
love through the
year but this something
about the or the Terry
quality of Italian that in a bridge
you must've been because it was
that sensation of being surrounded by it you
know Florence went where I first found
myself. And it was like
that how I describe it
that that that that
is you know before this
began and everybody was sort of talking in the end and that's how
it felt it was that sort
of murmuring collective something that I
knew people were saying things but I couldn't distinguish what anybody with the family came on stage
just you know something
that yes but that's how I describe it in the book you know is what I found when
I was in Florence I was like I
was it was like I had walked in and you know all of these people were just sort of talking
and and I was I just wanted to understand what they were saying.
It was that it was just a desire to
understand. That led me on this and the
law. Was a kind of recognition.
Well there was a rocket recognition and that's
why
Strangely it's hard for me to think it's hard for me to
call Italian a foreign language. I mean I know it is. But I
can't
bear to call it Pat says I don't think of it that way you
know it
feels familiar to me and it felt familiar to me from the
very
beginning. Before I understood a word of it. Just the way I think some people
you meet and you do feel like you've known them. You've
already known them even though you just sort of talking to them and I. You're in the middle of a canvas and
if you're already. You've already gone somewhere together. Who knows how
or where I don't
know reminds me of a poem.
Since I have more memories and if I was a
fan I somehow feel that there is something that
preceded the
initial approach. Of the port.
Yes And so you're already in the middle of it you know.
And this happens sometimes when you're lucky. You know I when I met my husband I
thought that one with certain friends. I feel that it's like
well but we're already friends. We're already friends. We're just it's just a
matter of actually knowing what your name is but we already know each other you
know but you have this certain people right now with everybody but
with some people you do.
Thankfully not and very very yes they very thankfully I would
be deliberating but also very exhausted.
I just already
exhausted exhausting all.
Because it's so immersive.
And
what struck me also is that when you left you left your
library behind you left everything
you
could.
So I do know your library and since the best I could just just died and
he was on the stage many many times is a line of his which I love where he says the
contents of someone's bookcase a part of his history like and
Sestriere portrait. So you but you
you abandon your English library you say seventy nine of my
books useful anymore.
They seem like ordinary objects of my creative
life disappears the stars that. Guided me
recede and this kind of India violent gesture
of getting rid of it. I wonder what.
What's in
that I mean except for that dictionary that
you carry around before coming down here we went to the special collections
and saw some extraordinary objects I
think books of Shelley and Byron but the one that really
caught your attention was a dictionary called an
interpreter credible.
Speak about
recognition. Exactly you know why did I call
my first book that.
Anyway
but but your question is yes
this is why this.
This. Breaking. The points
of reference. Well. It's I think I
mean and I don't mean in terms of just how heavy things are to carry I think.
There's more to
life you know there's there's much more I mean I think on some level clearly I am trying
to experience
something that is very much a part of my family history which is
leaving right. Leaving those points of reference what that means.
What
the
what the danger of that is what the
benefits of that may be what the mystery of that is that all of the insecurity that
is churned up as a result of of leaving that port
of you know.
In which one is secure or one feels secure and rooted and where things make
sense so you know having
parents who who did that.
Or
were or. Who chose. I mean one
chose to do that and the
other followed and had other feelings about about
this voyage about the
departure but in some sense I
think I mean we're always trying to figure out our parents right.
And and I haven't really stopped and
so I think there's
that there's that behind it. But I
think apart from the kind
of you know familial model and my curiosity my kind
of lifelong curiosity
about you know that fundamental.
Act of my parents you know to to go away
that definitive moment that voyage. That decision.
I
think as an artist I did it also for
myself you know it wasn't just to say just to think what is
it like to leave your. You
know your known. Set of variables for
an onset unknown set of variables. I think it.
There was something more on the creative
level play and play with his you know I
think story in the sense that you become.
Somehow self-sufficient.
No I know nothing's no. Stoicism I did it all out of
love and devotion willing
you know it. I mean when you love something you just do anything for it right you live
for it and
so yes one day I stopped reading in English because I felt it
was it was interfering and I wanted to just concentrate on
Italian and because that is something
I mean important for people to understand this if you
actually have this right in English.
Stop. I mean just cut your ties for a while
you with this language. If you don't call your
mother which you know to me of course resonates tremendously
because I grew up more or less as a linguistic monster myself
with many languages and I want to say that I had no mother tongue
but several father times you know. Somehow I didn't quite
have
it all talk about that. But.
But no I
think again I've lost my that's about to say I think when you say such
interesting things and I
get that you know that. I think it's because I have I have
no losing your train of thought and if you think that
I'm keeping my wrong.
I mean I don't
know that's partly what happens when. If it's
true it will come to me or maybe not
I like what you said to me you know. Maybe I never told you
but when we came back
from Rome in the
fall I called
you right.
It was a very intense conversation you and I had for various reasons but
I I said to you.
Well
I don't really want to come back Paul but I'm going to try. I'm going to try to get used to things
again
here and you said but maybe you won't.
And I thought that was such a nice thing for you to say you know it just it just took all
the pressure off and I thought yeah maybe I won't. And that's OK
too. You know because I've always been.
I've always found it felt the obligation to always kind of conform to everything I have to do
this now I'll do it this way I have to do this I teach you this way and when you just when you
said well maybe you won't. And I thought yes maybe I won't.
Maybe I won't. Maybe it will be resolved and imperfect
and there will be that irritant.
This whole notion of you know I have a great affection for
this whole notion of.
Well that's the thing I mean because I you know I talk about this book the
balance the triangle and all of these things and I
think yes we seek balance and everybody. Wants to
be peaceful and harmonious and balanced and all of these
things are good but well.
I
mean yes or no but I mean I think if you're creating
you
know if you're living. If you're choosing to live outside
the balance zone. You
know and if you're actually more interested in disrupting the balance and turning it
upside down and poking into it and taking it apart and pulling the
threads out I mean this is what we're doing as as artists right through this is life is yes it would
be nice if it were all nice
and harmonious and ordered. But this order is the greater
power right. And so if you're in and
that you have to be in touch with that
you know you have to let it happen. You.
Yes because it's all I mean it's all well and good for me to say.
Oh you know in the middle of my life
I I learned Italian and I you know I was
like tightening. My gaiety.
But it's one thing to just to conceive of it that way and say
I guess there was the. Bengali there was the English there was the continuous
war there was the crisis the anxiety and then along comes the Taliban and
then everything is just kind of harmonious situation but it's
not it's not at all it's it's so much more complicated now but it's
good it's a good. It's a it's a good complications a good state
of you know it just how do you resolve
something you don't you complicate it.
You know and that's what I try to teach my students you know I don't I don't don't make don't tie it up at
the end. You know take it somewhere. Enrich it
complicated deep in it leave it ambiguous. This is life not
the other way around.
I mean I feel there's so much in the chair I said you know people sometimes ask me
to moderate and I say but I'm not
moderate I would know how to do that I can instigate I cannot
facilitate you know when people tell me. Could you facilitate this conversation I feel like you
know they need to take some pills for digestion. I mean it just it just makes no sense
to me to facilitate the conversation but rather to show different sides
of
it but you know what what struck me also in the way you were
describing and then Bengali and then this. This is a kind of work that a
biographer Slater a simple biographer might try
to show would be with this period that period and then it was resolved by
this but I were lives are lived in very different ways and described in the
biography that tries to make sense of my life right away.
I remember the thread that I
have and I don't remember I remind
you you said something about but
you're talking about the sort of renunciation moment that I
was a writer in in the English language and you know and then so
to stop reading in English and to do these things signified you
know and it's true.
I I was a writer in the English language.
I was but I don't I didn't think of it that way
because because of this gap. I
felt all my life between me in English which going
into Italian I suddenly when I looked back I saw that it was
there because I don't think that it would have been possible for me to do what I've
done.
If that bond were
more solid. You know there was always this
room
for slippage between me and all of the languages
right and and what I
think that was sort of the revelation the space between us that there is
no I'm not against you know and this. We now
can
perhaps discuss the hotly debated mother tongue topic if you wish
or not wish but but in any case this. This is the this is the
realisation is that even
though I left the house and Brooklyn full
of so many books in English that has shaped me informed me and inspired me
for so many years. I felt that there was a there.
Why didn't I miss them.
You can look at asking me but don't you miss reading in English what's what don't you miss it.
That's wrong but I'm with you you know there's only one with you it's like don't you miss your kid
you know and I didn't I didn't miss
English the kids maybe not. So that's the
thing but it was like almost something
unnatural like what do you mean you don't miss that if that's a part of you
you have to miss it you
know. But I didn't miss it I really
didn't feel freedom
from I did I felt freed and I felt turned on by something else
completely that was
opening up my mind and my soul and
everything was things were happening that
were surprising that I thought well I got
this one life and yes I have spent many years
reading adoring worshipping.
Writers in English so why not if I have the ability now
to deepen my understanding of Italian through reading which is
the primary you know.
I mean the writing is a kind of a minor project compared to
the reading which is really
the what I'm doing here and reading in Italian
you know
and
can I share nice news with you today. I don't think it's a secret
but so today I was asked to be. One
of the
voters for the sake of
prize and I was so moved on and started crying.
I thought I can't believe this you know I've been
trusted to vote. For.
You know the Strayer prize which is the most
important prize in
in Italy for literature and to read for fiction.
And they're trusting me they're giving me this vote and I
thought
I earned that you know with all of the study with all of this reading with all of
this this dip dedication of you know and maybe
the I mean if I hadn't if I hadn't stopped writing and reading in English
sorry if I hadn't made this sort of radical if I hadn't taken that
radical
step.
Perhaps that would have happened. You know because I think it's it over
time that I read and I read and I keep reading and
then you know I am able to read.
People's novels and talk about them and then I you know I enroll more wherever
I present them and and then you know it sort of suddenly becomes
apparent Oh she can she can
read that and she can understand and she can talk about it and all these things and
I I was just
over were so overwhelmed this morning by this this this email I really. Anyway.
But it was it
was not anyway you know I mean it was I was
very moved I really I was
I I'm so honored. It's such a big honor for me
to to to do this.
And
so that's when you could really imagine.
No none of
it would switch.
But I did like a
time
because there
was no ambition. I mean there was ambition and that I wanted
to but you know. Just to and with
that also you know when people
say
that from assume I think this is so
missing the point because missing often. It's not a
part of you.
Well exactly I mean look if someone
said you know you've been away for five months.
Don't you miss your family and I said Well not really well then that person would
have a reasonable right to say well maybe there's something going on with that
family
right because the ordinary person would say well yes of course I miss them
because you're connected to them that's the thing you're connected to them and your life
is is a whole with them together and a web
of affection of love of rituals of day to day
everything you know it's like they form your identity right.
So that's what I'm talking about
so but but but but being away from
English going away leaving the books behind and not missing them.
Shed light on the fact that the relationship. It was
perhaps more complicated than I
realized and he's also you know it alls for permitting a certain freedom that
you speak about in the book and we've spoken about this once before.
It reminds me of that great moment in maces Eric Our
where he talks about arriving in is somebody without any book since
the war and
he sort of ruminating and thinking that it
is precisely because he doesn't have a library that he's able to write probably
one of the greatest books of literary criticism ever written.
If he was freed
of of the impediment.
Now is a book it's a very basic travel metaphor. Yeah. Write it
with which I mean of the various metaphors at play in the
book in my
book that is kind of the key. Yeah right it's it's
the going away. It's it's the the sailing. However you want to call it but
it's it's it's Odysseus it's the desire to tell one
story as the unknown as the
other masked getting in the other land. You know I'm going to talk about
myself and I'm going to tell you about my adventures but I'm going to pretend not to be who I
am an awful thing of course he returned and that that is you know.
But it is that impulse. It's the voyage. It's it's like the you
know it's the beginning of literature right. It's it's that's
how literature is
born the voyage the going away the unknown the
encounter with the other and the becoming the
other and so I feel like in my own small way
I'm responding to that you know I'm responding in this book
to decades. Reading I'm responding to be a being a student at Barnard
College in the eighty's and having my head spinning
with ideas and feeling overwhelmed in the best
of ways
by too much I mean by the too much of it all.
Exactly and I think in this book I. In Italian
I'm able to start really looking and thinking about all
of what has gone in
uncirculated sedimented and all of that you
know with a certain strange
clarity in spite of all of the kind
of difficulties the awkwardness. The brusqueness the lack
of grace in spite of those things.
There's just that sheer that sheer will to see things clearly
for want
of you to feel about you your rediscovery of
reading again this notion of slowness of reading in Italian as a way of going
back to the initial immersive quality of reading as a
child. You say I read as I did when I
was as a writer I
rediscover the pleasure of reading. Reminding me
of a wonderful line of color who speaks about
the slowness in this movement of slow food in it.
And also in the world in the movement also which he thinks should exist
of slow reading. You
know there is a pace at
which if one reads writes one. And if one
reads too quickly maybe one doesn't
understand when we read too fast or too slow. We understand
nothing like Pascal says constantly Toby to talk to
small. You're
a new thing. So I'm wondering if the experience of learning and reading
in Italian has taught you to read in a different way.
So young in what way. Well.
I mean I have to read. More actively Right. Because
it's I'm going. I mean now it's different now I been
reading for four years I just read in Italian so I found
a certain.
More or less I just go you know it's not like four years
ago when I was just filling up notebook after notebook with all of these
words I didn't know and you know it was a kind of. It was a very different
kind of experience you know because I my vocabulary was was very
scant
and and I was reading literature so you know I mean I was reading writers
and I just I could access it. I mean I
knew more or less what was being said but I wasn't I wasn't getting it I wasn't getting the
the depth of it the the all of the the the so
much what I was just
I couldn't get the subtleties right the shadings of the language and then
there were simply millions of things like I simply didn't understand at all like what does that word mean I don't
know I had to look it
up because all of this is happening alone. You know but
nobody's helping me nobody's reading with me I'm not reading for a class I'm not reading with a
teacher I mean I work hard on my conversation with
with
people so people would
say See Chikezie this is you know and they would they would
force that
muscle into some. Coherent shape.
But the reading was a very solitary you know deliberate deliberate
path of my own and I had different strategies that
I kind of talk about in the book and you know. I
realized I mean I remember even in Rome in the beginning I would read.
In this in this you know I had a whole set up you know I would have had the book and then I
had the the dictionaries and then the little notebook and you know
I just I had all of the I needed it I needed. All I needed the support kind
of
and and now I I need it less you know I mean I underline the
word here or there. Sometimes I don't Sometimes I know all the words you
know
and the dictionary doesn't go with you everywhere anymore.
Well the original dictionary that I talk about in Florida.
It's a character. Yes they're really the main character.
I think that he's here John why you love. I did and it was cold because I was different
I did as a bar of
soap and that one was also I mean you know it had that
green bar of soap like kind of the
quality but the original dictionary that I
bought in Boston before
going to
Florence for the first time. That I
keep Now in my drawer and in my my desk and it just
is
there because. It doesn't help me anymore because it's an it's
not a monolingual dictionary and so. I mean I won't say I know all the
words in it I
don't but but your word but of gradual but the words I do I have in the words
I tend to look up. Aren't there
anymore so I just keep it in a
drawer and now I carry around with me I have
various pocket Italian dictionaries that are just in Italian.
I mean I noted there was a moment in my along this road.
You know you have certain signposts when you look back and you say oh this was this. Was when I started.
You
know but there was a moment
in in Rome actually. You know because
I have these little notebooks I have my own kind of I'm private lexicon
at this point of these little notebooks where I just write all the words that I don't
know and so many of the first notebooks were all filled
with
the definitions in English right so. Because he had
a glass whatever I mean I just kept writing the the definitions in English and that a
certain point I just I realize all the definitions were being written in Italian just out of
it like something happened in my
head and I didn't know that I wasn't even aware of it exactly.
So now for years when I look up words and I write them I don't I don't
write the definition and. In English I write it in a
talent.
And that was when I switched over to all of the monolingual dictionaries. So I just.
You know I have a I bought it the labyrinth bookstore and Princeton.
You know I was desperate I thought I can't have an office that an Italian dictionary in it
right that's not right and I went and I got the
the most kind of bearable. Look like the big the best one I I
brought it back to the
office and every time I tried to look up a word it's out there.
I mean the words I need aren't in the dictionary anymore and I but I hate the online dictionary I mean I go to
it of course I have to sometimes. The library and print from I love the library my
God it's so nice when it's like the nicest thing in Princeton.
Firestone the Firestone
is really knowing that open. You know interest for in the morning.
Well I don't live there so I don't know but maybe when I live there. If I can't sleep it finds some point I
think I'm going to go tell your dictionary. Well it's just a beautiful library. You know.
Really is and
I scoped out the whole
Italian section. They know who they are
so we never we
never stop
trying to. To understand I will
parents at one
point very much towards the end of your book you say I came to it.
Partly to know my character
inspector comma my parrot.
Extraordinary
sentence my characters
better not have a few. But after that with comes.
Well I mean so many of my characters were inspired by my parents writer
not specifically by my parents but but my parents' lives
their experiences. Their load of being
their concerns
their you know their
reality the reality they carry within them that
I was that I was exposed to and sensitive to and privy to which I
knew was at at odds with the reality at large
in my life growing up here. And so when
you. When you're raised by people who are living in a different reality.
You
know a state of constant.
Yes constant nostalgia constant What does this word mean I mean constant
you know trying to figure it out constant you
know anxiety. You know in
some sense.
Not without their bearings. You know not without
some entity. And of course with
time yes then this
process even fast a little bit and one learns
and learned to cope and survive and build and enjoy and
move forward in another world. But you know but but
I am the first child and I
are beginning
are you know my parents just.
Just figuring it all out.
And that. That's those are my first seven years. You know that
marked me so profoundly.
I can't really if I have any point of reference it's
that it's all of that anxiety
and confusion and distress
and
everything by the way happening in another language not in
English we had no people who spoke English ever came into our
home.
So that's how it
was and. Has
been transformed into for.
Kind of place. And the federal
for not the homeland but it's it's it's
I mean the whole world
of the whole idea of mythology so interesting you know this kind of a.
Yes
it's a home that you have made for us it's
not like the home of
your parents was a specific place that was this is a
place that has become yours out of kind of a deliberate.
Yes it's a nostalgia that I've created. It's a sickness that
I've that I went out and expose myself to on purpose. You know.
But I think it.
We spoke about that a little bit you know the whole idea of the Felder was created in
the seventeenth century. With
physicians who discovered that the Swiss
Army mercenaries were missing there. And so
he created the girls kind of for the
homeland to incredible.
I mean that is an invented word is incredible you know just from the linguistic point of view that
that very powerful because I think language.
Is one of the principal tools for.
I hate this verb battling but I guess one of the principles two tools
for for for coping with
nostalgia for feeling it. You
know I mean all of poetry. So much of poetry
is coming out of that in it and
that what is the what is the way to express this
it's language right and it's so it strikes me that it's the word itself isn't as kind
of deliberate construction around these two Greek you
know what
would we do without. With you I mean we need.
Well
I think I mean I maybe I think so I mean I was I
was strangely jealous of my mother's nostalgia though. As I watched
her being consumed by
it as I watched her suffering from it so deeply.
You know and all I wanted to do as a child was take on a style just way. I just wanted
to smother it with a blanket. Because I knew how painful it
was for her. To feel
it and I just I everything I was just I was and I was of
course powerless to do anything because it was so
huge and the place was so far and the relationship was so
this broken and distant and never enough never enough.
Nothing and nothing ever satisfied. You know no trip. If it was one
month couldn't it be two months it was two months why couldn't it be four months it was six months
why couldn't it be a year. You
know. So when you're
watching you know when I was watching my mother going through this
and I thought she's still going through it. He hasn't stopped.
Really it's changed but it hasn't stopped
and and I just I wanted so desperately to to make it go
away and the fact that I couldn't do it made me
so.
I just I just hope somehow I could do something about it I mean I
remember once I gave her little I gave her
a wallet. And as a gift and I went to Calcutta
and I took a photograph of the building where she was
raised you know her her. IFTIKHAR her
everything you know her frame of reference the place where she was
happy right. I took a little picture of it and I put it in the
little transparent window and I gave this to her as a gift and I thought well
maybe every time she opens up the wallet. She'll see the the photograph of
the building.
But these are other things for a child to write. Maybe not
so I don't I mean I love my mother I wanted her to feel
better you know.
But but then what happens. Years later.
I mean I can I make this journey on my own
and on purpose everything on purpose everything sort out everything
to
deliberate and then I come back and. I find
myself suffering in my own way.
Very
last very looking at pictures of my apartment and staring at the
computer screen thing. Oh yes there is my desk you
know. But I was strangely proud of
that feeling because I felt that it meant that I was
somewhere in my
heart but that the physical place. I mean
I
already rooted in many ways you know I did my family I did with
my my children my husband I'm rooted with my work with my
books in any language and those things.
And I have been for some time you know I think
ever since the moment I became a writer I felt somehow.
OK I'm connected somehow to the world to the universe.
It's going to be OK.
I love in your book where you say Today I no longer feel.
To risk a lost country to my parents. It took me a
long time to
accept that my writing did not have to assume that responsibility in
that sense in other words it's the first book I've written.
But also from the linguistic point of view as a
child I continue as a writer to seek the truth. But I don't give the
same weight to affect trends in Italian and moving
towards
abstraction. The place is defined the characters
and nameless without the particular cultural. And. The result
I think is writing that is fried in certain ways from the concrete.
One can screw
up and less be sued for
expecting. A simple question with you what you mean
by
obstruction. Well I mean
exactly
what it what it is is as you know abstract in that it could be any
place that that the need for this specific place falls away because again I
mean to go back to the little wallet
anecdote. What is that about it's the fact that a specific play is
one place in the world one
building in one city.
You know in the world is
is the center of you know what I perceive to be the center of my mother's happiness and well
being and so the distance from that city the the going
back to that house staying in that house everything is sort of determined by that one
specific
building right. And
so in a way I mean. So yes on the one hand
I'm sort of jealous of my my mother's nostalgia and jealous of that sense
of I OK there's a place in the world that that that is so
important and that I'm so identified with that this is kind of the thing that defines me even if I can't
have it.
It defines me you know I define myself in opposition or in in absentia
I'm still defined by it right and on the other hand
I
feel you know I just I just want to
obliterate the power that it has the power that place
has you know I just wanted. It's like all of this all of this
identity the whole business
that identity is is something that I
think I'm really thinking about very different. The right now
and trying to get beyond it and trying to sort of you know get to the
other side of all of these labels
and everything you know your language writer in the English language over
your Indian American obit Calcutta
Oh but this is no you know and I feel like I feel all of the books I've written
until this. They're all about that it's all in a sense.
Trying to put into books the picture in that wallet
to say that's a common my parents.
Yes that's it it's like how can I render present.
How can I bring to them what is
missing and should the child. As you were saying earlier feel that.
I mean which
yes yes and so if I write stories now that have nothing to
do with that
specific neighborhood that street that building those times. I'm
free free I'm free because I feel like now I can express I can write really what are what
I want and what I need to write without fine and yes and this is
very liberating for
me this is very liberating for me because I think the whole all of the past four
books the frame of reference of
my parents in fact I know it you know.
In an earlier conversation we had I'm on now on a series I have called a phone call
from pawn you you mentioned to me.
Your discovery in Italian of a Romanian writer who wrote in
French with magnificent great or
not very well known in America but the little bit Susan Sontag made
him somewhat well known at a point when people read Susan
Sontag called I know my students read how do you make one so your students
know you're home the great Rumanian writer who wrote a book
called in English it's called The trouble with being born but. Correct translation
it's of the inconvenience. Of the inconvenience
of being born and I thought I would read you one passage and just
have you react to it and the passage goes like
this everyone has had at a given
moment an extraordinary experience which will be for him.
Because of the memory of
it he preserves the crucial.
Obstacle to his metamorphosis.
Well I mean every word he writes in this book is is
very powerful you know I yes I read I mean it was
a we have certain books that we read and
they one never forgets experience of reading
them so reading this book in Italian for me was was one of those
it wasn't even maybe it was a year ago so fairly
recent A friend told me about the book I'd never heard of
him but a friend of mine who is actually the translator the
Italian translator. Have got others.
Her name is.
I think is her last name anyway.
She
she told me about him one day we were having dinner she said you know you know
children children children and I
said I said yes' and I mean she said well you must you must read
him you know because he writes about he writes
all about his passage from Romanian to French
and I think you're really going to you know you're going to
say that I think you need to read him.
And. You know it's was one of those life changing encounters with the with
the mind with and and
and this book in particular I mean he writes. So.
Powerfully succinctly about so many of the themes. I think that that have
been preoccupying me as a person I mean I'm not talking about this was
of well it's interesting that's the heart of the book right and also
the what you read is is you
know is is certainly resonates on many many levels in terms
of but it's interesting what you say but the obstacle to metamorphosis. You know and maybe
the obstacle to metamorphosis. Yes he says it. The obstacle
to metamorphosis is that sense of.
I mean you know
I saw one of these one of the other extraordinary things about my learning
Italian is that I was able to then
have.
You know psychotherapy in Italian Right after years
of in English so this is a whole other fascinating journey I was
making right in another language and I I'm curious now I'm very curious I've talked to some
people about you know what it means
to have that experience in IT IN learned language.
But you know one of the. One of the things that you
know. She told
me very early on was you know every
change necessitates a betrayal.
So you know on you can get mentally ready men though.
So
well when you read that to me I think OK Yes I went through this
I sort of.
And
she she I mean I don't want to talk about my psychotherapist that was bad but there but you know
she there words that she said she that she uses that are
helpful to me is you know she says things like you know stay out of Korea though.
You know you are creating
yourself in what you're doing this is part of what you're
doing and she's right of course and this
this will
metamorphosis. You know not a natural metamorphosis I'm not a caterpillar but of I mean
this is
not genetically programmed into me right.
And
so in some sense I'm doing something very unnatural. And the
other day at the Italian embassy and in Washington. I talked
about and other sort of metaphor that came to
me after writing out about all the. The term
an Italian is is in NESTORE. Which means
graft right. The botanical term. To graft
and and I think this is another one of those key
metaphors for what's happening here for me on the little linguistic level. I am trying
to graft myself onto Italian Why because I'm trying
to grow in some other in
another way another direction with some you know and what is the point of
the graft. What is the point of the nest with to to obtain a
new food a perhaps a better food right. So I think is a very interesting metaphor
and in fact I discovered by reading I was reading and then I found.
And in life you know Scooter.
Which is translated as the carrier the last child maybe
a lost
daughter.
She there's a moment in which the mother
character this sort of troubled one of the many probabl mother characters in the novels about
an affair and the and she's talking about her relationship to her two
daughters and she says you know she's
she's commenting on how they're different from
from from from herself and how they're traits that are more like her husband with
whom she has a of course naturally a strange
relationship always things and she's only one point they never
could for Sunni nesters well yet though. I fear that it was a that
was that that was a failed the nest Oh this this bond with her
children the failed graft.
And I was really. Very struck by that
terminology the failed graft and I I thought about it I thought about it and I wrote
a piece about it actually in Italian could kind of try
to pick it apart and unpack it a little bit
and and I do think that what I'm doing with the language
is there is there's that element
of you know the fear the fear that it's going to be a failed graft
and so many people have criticized me for what I'm doing you know from the very beginning from even before I wrote
the book you know. You know don't do this don't do
this be good it's bad it's bad career it's bad for you it's
bad for them it's bad for everybody just don't do it just walk away but just walk away.
Just go away you know from just walk away from the room you
know because they
know well they still may be right
but but the point
is it's it was so when you make the nest.
I mean it's sort of you know in good faith and you hope
you put it together. Dr WOOD. Yes. You put it together you join these
you fuse these elements and then you kind of
hope that something will solidify and that
over time something will come of that kind of operate
does an operation right on
purpose to to
join to to regenerate in some way.
Right so this whole outdoor Gratz yarn if you know what is that all about is sort of this
we generative impulse a remaking impulse.
But I mean I
think so many artists on so
many paths
are. What is the word so many points along the journey.
Do things like this you know and
hope and hope and and throw away and don't look the other way
and stop doing what they're doing and what I meant
by Little did they know that you would
stop you
know you will very deliberately
prove persevering
regardless but that's the adolescent part of this midlife crisis but maybe midlife crises
are basically a second adolescence maybe this is nothing new but it's true but it's
better that's what it is you know I mean. And it was it was interesting because you know I
was thinking a lot of us Philip Guston before I went to Rome. Because he went to Rome.
Of course and it was in Rome that he had his we thinking.
Back
to the figurative you know or to the figurative.
And
and I too was looking for something. And I I mean how does Philip got you know
I have a Philip Guston beautiful postcard of a book one of his
books of right over my desk in Brooklyn. I look at it all the time
right and.
Little did I know that
this all of this would start to happen.
The Metamorphosis the graft. But
again you have there is a betrayal implicit.
You know and maybe part of the betrayal is being able to say to
myself I can write what I want to write how I want to
write in whatever language I choose to write and I don't have to listen to
everybody telling me how to write it. What to write about and what language to
use
the noise around. Yes I promised everybody in
thing free for you've named for them to hear
your seven words. OK Here you have seven
words. In Italian and maybe
maybe then you can translate them as you did for me in English.
OK found something.
Which I translated as without a mother tongue by
words.
Five words.
Could have been used or and
so beautifully by me Loesch where he says language.
I was reminded of it when reading you know the
word I'd like to close by reading a
passage.
Why do I write. To investigate the mystery of
existence to tolerate myself to get closer. To everything that is outside
of
me if I want to understand what moves me what confuses me what
pains me everything that makes me react in short I have to put it into
words writing is my only way of absorbing and organizing life.
Otherwise it would terrify me it would upset me too
much with passes without being put into words without being
transformed and in a certain sense purified by the crucible of writing has no
meaning for me only words that seem real and they have
a
power of various a period to us. Given that
I try to decipher everything through writing maybe writing in Italian is simply my
way of learning the language in a more profound more stimulating
way ever since I was a child I belonged. Only to my
words I don't have a country specific culture. If I didn't
write if I didn't work with words I wouldn't feel that I'm
present on those what does the word mean and the life in the end it seems
to me the same
thing just as a word can have many dimensions many
nuances great complexity so too can a person a life.
Language is a mirror and the principle of
metaphor because ultimately the meaning of a word like that of
a person is. Boundless
ineffable Now I've asked John Boehner he read to read that
passage in the original in Italian.
Thank you.
Take
is cleaver. That in the garden he stated it is there just
answer the tell that Artemis Tesa that have if he had to touch
OK he's over the forty the
men tell you could be a queer looking you call peace quite like me
confound could have been younger. Breaded to to Chuck in me for
a little metal Imperioli. The three to a
new only co model there a sort of B. to it but system and I viewed
her as three men team is going to school mentor in the U.S. convoy
her bitter Opal.
Chalk it past the censors had a message missing but all the censor said it as a transformer
to an inch at a percent so what if you got all the coach wall O. the last
previewed it and he can laugh at men.
So if at all they could run on the sand and rarely.
A lot of superiority
annoyed the surveyor provided she fretted to try me to last three
to were forced to scream any Tell Ya know some bitch I meant in your model but apprehended in a
lean one and not a few profound though used to malign
the thing that I got has been that I got other tangles than telling
me about only one owned by a zone a call to a place she's
a sentence previously said on Lover S.C.L. a
parolee not me centered I present us with a
terra cotta scene if you can up at all or a
Ryvita a burial a female officer causa common about all
of our That Atlanta dementia only than to swim a two way when at that accomplish heat
or clean up their sauna. When I have
Lisa Ling Well a spec you limit Dafur a pretty
choppy plain cheap Principe Alex was at that again in
founders and if you've gotten up at all a cosy comic. Well loading up a sauna.
It will cause a nice Ms rattle the in a fabulous.
AAA hearing. Thank you very much
if you lose.